I'M N
LEARN A FEDERAL JUDGE WILL RUIN
SNRAIT THARULING
SAME JUDGE HAS JUS ALED INVENT
ERT DOCUMENTS UN
ASE ORE TH00 MARKINGS ALONG WITH
CLOTHING AMONG OTHER THINGS.ND E
STATEMENT SAYIER.
L,
RNED.WAS HOW MANY O
THDOS WERE
, SOME FROM TH
FONT'S O
RAGEO AND SOME
S CE EVIDENCE  T FI WAITIALLWERO
U JUST
OF BS AT THERE
ARTICLESUMENTS, THREES GIFTS
TO BE.T IN A SECURE FILING SYSTE
D G INTHAT THE VOLUME , YOTALKED
00 IFIED DOMERN.IAY GIVEN THE
NATIONAL ARCHIVES 15 BOXES S AF
OEG RYTHING ELSE. F0 MORE
NONCLASSIFIEDOS ON C
THATN TALKING
>> ALL OVER TO THEL CHIVES BECAU
EYTHAT THERE WER90 EMPTYOINT TH
RETURN TEDKIS,SAID
THEY  PERHAPS WE RAGAIN, IT RA
OS
ABH OF RAND HOW THEYERHANDLED.
UPDATE ON THEI
E
E R WILL INFS  G CRIMINALVEIG HI
WERE ALL ANXIOUS CHAMPING AT HE
RULIN
E THATAS
IT HAST UST YEE SPIC O
D YESTERDAY IN C WT CLINED D>>
THE SPECIAL MATELR REHEHE
SO CER THAONE.E'HE GHE
IS STILL OPEN TO THE IDEA.
SHE HASN'T MADE HER RULING YSHE
WAT AND
SOS.HING W
CONVERSAH FORMER
FRIDAY.OIN
E THISAILED LISTENTORY.
>> I TALLYND
HAARE 35, THAT
VETHT SAY
OCUMENTS THAT WERE
IN TO ASK YOURSELFNTEVERYTHING,U
THAT
PR CONCE A
>> WE KNOWS MAD CLSI MARKINGS .
FIANAI MORE THAN 100
F TH
D HAD THE SIFIED MARKINGS.ERE ,0
IN CLASSIFIED S FO-A-LAGO.HE SHM
CT THE
CASE TNK HE.HOWS THAEVERE AND TO
THAT IE AHME HRTNLO
NOT LIKEE EVER CLAIMTHERE WAS MI
MEA LO CUMENTS AND VERYPO
ERE SEIZEDIS OFFIC E
DOCUMENTS
INTERMIN WITH OTR THINGS, S,
CLOTHING ITEMS.
LES  SPECIAL
MASTT E  SPE M
SA A A UPISRMSTN?AIR QUESTION.H
I ME, S THE
JUDGE WHO HI
ND
CH WARRANT, THEY A
LEANING
TERMS ENDENT
ABLE TO PUA T IS ON .
BUE E
, THAT UNDER THE
IS GOO
REASON IN THIS CTO
SPECIAL MASTER.
TYPICAL LAWYERKE THE GIULIANI C
E LAWND THERES EF LINTS AN    F
ATTORNEY/CLIENT IV
INFORMATION A LOT
Y ISN'
MUI H
DO T
GOH THIS INITIALLYTHT MANYEVEN R
L THOSCUMENTS ARE EV ED THE'T AH
THT RS HAD SEARCH WARRT
UT YHE F
REAL QUI
G VOUERS.
THE AMF INVESTATE IT
RIULYOM AN
INDEPENDENT ALREAD
LOOKING  TUMENTS?
ARE
PUY. YOU
DEP OF PEOPL
O KEEP IT INO WITH
COMPLETE SE, T UGH AND TRENT PRG
DOCUMENTS.
ATY WHAT A
ER
I MEANVERY
CLIVILEGE ONT OHAID THIS ON ESDE
ST>> GIVEN THAT IT IS DONALD TRP
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT, I
SURPRISED  SLI AND I
D IF THERE MOR CLASSIFIED
>>E THAT.S
DO YOU THINK THAT WE'LL SEE A
OTHER TRUMP ERTIES?
>> I DON'T KNOW.
I THINK IT ALLEP
THE FBI